start the day by cleaning your mind your
wondering mind
and it really increases the focus and
productivity so it's a great tool and
you can use it during the day for five
minutes between meetings and then come
first to the next meeting you will be
much more efficient and effective and
productive
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctek
hello and welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders we're talking about
leadership and the wisdom to lead meet
karen zuk the ceo and founder of wisdom
to lead
keren zuk phd is a sought after speaker
consultant and thought leader in the
21st century of leadership as founder of
consulting firm wisdom to lead she
specializes in the development of senior
management teams and corporate
leadership tsuk guides companies and
senior management teams to reach their
full potential using various techniques
in the field of mindfulness she is also
the author of mindfully wise leadership
the secret of today's leaders
dr karen tsuk welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for joining me
today
thank you for having me
i'm
looking forward to talking about
leadership
i get to talk to a lot of startups and a
lot of investors about their particular
method of leadership and what that means
to them
you have a phd from the hebrew
university and leadership in the 21st
century you're the ceo and founder of
wisdom to lead and so um you know over
the more than a decade you're you're
investigating you're helping companies
and and individuals become better
leaders and and do it more intentionally
and it works more thoughtfully so i'm
looking forward to understanding your
holistic view and and maybe touching on
a few case studies of of how to well how
we can see good or bad leadership and
learn from there so karen thank you very
much for joining me
thank you looking forward
so kevin how does one get to become an
expert in leadership and as the marches
do a phd in leadership how does that
happen
first of all
you know it's
leading by example so it starts with
ourselves so
evolving as a person as an individual
and growing to new areas to new zones
and
working with 20 years of working with
leaders in promoting change and growth
so you you learn from the experience
you're working for with people and you
evolve
to the situation
and the experience so you know i've as
you said i did a conducted a case study
two years in a heightened company
because i was really interested to learn
what's happening when the theory meets
the
field you know it's really nice theories
but then we need to deliver right we
need to to engage people it's not enough
to to write the article
and i was really my leading question
with what is what is the role of leaders
nowadays he needed financially
successful organization alongside
motivating and engaging the employees
from intrinsic motivations
and enabling them to fulfill themselves
and to be creative innovative
and i found you know um i found that
mindfulness is the crucial element that
leaders will need to embrace nowadays in
order to engage people to reinvent
ourselves
to
to evolve
and i'm
working with these tourism with this
experience in order to help people
to listen deeper to themselves to their
employees to the customers to the market
changing needs of the markets in order
to listen to what they really need and
from this place to create
products and services that add value to
the
community
so i think that you know one question
that i think we need to start with is
you know even going you know a little
bit higher up and understanding you know
what it what what are the complexities
of leadership and why why is this
something that we
as humans or you know just in general
why is this something that that that we
find difficult to really do really well
and when we do have some cases of people
who did this exceptionally well
throughout our history as is humanity
but why is it
an exception to be able to be a really
really good leader
because as i said before first of all we
need to be able to really listen to
what's needed and not act out of our ego
right in outward automatic behaviors
and to dare to pause and ask ourselves
tough questions and we don't like to
look in the mirror and say okay i was
wrong here i need to adjust i need to
pivot i need to change i made a mistake
and to take
accountability to be accountable for the
mistake and to be vulnerable
so we really need to connect to our
humanity
and to be able to connect to others and
at the same time to see the bigger
picture you know and not to be hooked up
in our story because it's only our story
but the story is much wider than
ourselves so it's the ability to also
listen to ourselves deeply and at the
same time to be able to listen to to see
the broader picture
and to decide how we want to act and
hold it these tensions between you know
as i say that a mindful leader
what characterizing three elements the
first one is the ability to be mindful
and present
the second one is that to hold pensions
you know the modern world is full of
tensions the organization would between
the short term and the long term right
between the employees needs and their
organization needs between speed and
quality
so i as a leader i need to be able to be
the uncertain to hold these tensions and
really listen and from this place to
enable the right and accurate solution
to emerge and we don't do it usually
usually we learn as leader that we need
to do and be doing more than to run and
not listen to what's happening and i can
you know like dog that runs after his
tale usually we run after our long times
right
right 100
so this connection of mindfulness to
leadership from what i'm understanding
from you it really stems in this ability
to pause
reflect and realize okay this is how i
may want to be doing something but there
is a new situation here that's unfolding
and if i'm mindful to it then maybe i
realize that my intuition is not
necessarily the right course of action
and i i'm able to lead better right and
this is where mindfulness is coming in
here just being more mindful of the
situation and being able to pause more
correct
yes and you know in my research and in
my book i'm talking about the central
tools for leaders and i call it a
dialogue space what does it mean a
dialogue space
continue what you said if we have a
a complex
product that we're offering want to
develop now or service
and we don't really know how to go
forward
it's the ability to create a space
and to explore together and come humble
and be present and share my experience
and my thoughts but i don't need to have
the answer it's okay to say okay this is
i think this the the way we are going
it's not the correct way we need to
pivot i don't know
what's the right way but my gut feeling
tells me that it's not the right way and
that's all right now listen to the other
people and respect other viewpoints
and create space to really explore to be
present coming with open mind open heart
and open wind
and once we create the space and it's
not easy to be there we need
at least one leader to be able to hold
the space
availability of respectful to other
people
we can create a place for new solutions
to emerge
and much more creative and innovative
so just also to understand the landscape
here we're talking about a leader you
know if you're imagining the persona of
the person that you know your work is
relevant to
is it is it mainly the leader of the
organization or are there more
types of people within an organization
or within you know the world that would
benefit from understanding a lot of
these concepts
so look we're talking you know
there's the traditional leadership
so first of all for your question it's
for each and every one of us it's
important and now i always say why
because you know the traditional
leadership uh
based on authority and title and
hierarchical relationships but we know
the workplace is changing right and the
leadership is changing and each and
every one of us needs to create
relationships based on trust and
partnership with our colleagues with our
employees with our vendors with
everybody we need to engage people from
a deeper place right they want to feel
meaning and
engage otherwise they won't come with us
so we need to be able to lead from a
different place
so this and you know the new leadership
it's
i see it as a social process it's not a
one leader that leads
the company there's a lot of leaders
there and every time another person is a
leader i can be a leader of a conference
you can be a leader of an idea of a team
it doesn't matter and it changes and we
need to use the wisdom of the crowd
right that makes sense okay so now let's
talk more tangibly about things that
perhaps you know we can do today through
your research
that may will make us more effective
more mindful leaders in the day to day
what are some things that i can do you
know starting in 10 minutes when our
conversation is over to become a better
leader myself
so first of all i recommend you know
it's not a must but it's a great way to
start the day by taking five or ten
minutes
uh meditating pausing if you don't like
me to meditate be with yourself go to
nature for 10 minutes but start the day
by cleaning your mind your wondering
mind
and it really increases the focus and
productivity so it's a great tool and
you can use it during the day for five
minutes between meetings and then come
first to the next meeting you will be
much more efficient and effective and
productive
so this one of the aspect another
thing to do is a leader for employees
be present with them you know it's
really critical nowadays to be there for
our employees so
ask your employees how you can be there
for them if you see a
employee struggling
refer to him emotionally ask him how can
you help him don't come with the
solution because we don't always have
the solution
if an employee or colleague feels seen
it's enough we don't need to do a lot
beyond that so this is another tip that
i can give that it's crucial
right now regarding this exact notion
that you just mentioned you know not
always having the solution you know
around around us as people you know
wha what have you been finding if we're
looking at the tech industry and we're
looking now at the positions of perhaps
ceos and and you know the executive
teams how is this something that is that
is relevant for the success of the
demise of a company for example because
i understand in the micro situations why
it may have effects both you know and on
personal relationships and on specific
decisions how do these things play out
in the greater context of the company
succeeding or failing
so let me let's talk let's talk about be
a as leaders the ability to be
vulnerable and authentic and connect
people to the broader picture and not
showing the rosy picture that it's not
really what's happening
so you know
in the company that i conducted my phd i
was really amazed to see it they were
struggling they were going through a
difficult uh financial times and they
stopped recruiting and you know people
starting talking and the anxiety
increases right because we when we don't
know what's happening
we feel anxiety and stress
and what amazed me that the ceo told me
you know i'm going to have a meeting a
company meeting and i'm going to share
with them the situation
and he was vulnerable and authentic and
he told him look this is the situation
right now we are not with putin anymore
for now we don't have i i don't have
answers for you
i can't guarantee what will be in six
months but once i will know i will let
you know
but the fact that he stood there
and showed up and was vulnerable and
authentic with them it was amazing
because people
stopped talking beyond the back you know
in
in closed doors because they feel part
of the process they knew
they felt safer now because they
understood that okay this is what's the
happening the ceo talked with us
is showed up he answered our questions
sometimes he didn't answer answers and
that's okay
but
this was amazing and people were really
relaxed once he talked with him even he
didn't give produce them the result you
know the
answers that they wanted but only
showing up is such such critical things
and another example i can give you from
a manager that went through my course
she also was a silly a vp in a big
company
and she went through the corona
beyond the coroner she also went through
a tough divorce
and she didn't share with her team what
she went through this
challenging time
and you
and she needed to you know and then also
the team also
a house breaking down and really not
pleasant situation
and during the course we talked about
vulnerability the ability to
dealing to show up to be authentic
and after the course she decided to
share with the team what she went
through and the challenging time she
went through
and she told me you know it was amazing
because foot first of all when i showed
up authentically and i was vulnerable
people connect with
patrick towered me right there they felt
her
and beyond that she told me it was
amazing because people started showing
up and one of my employees say that he
feel really lonely
and people didn't need to
to play a game that they didn't feel
like they could be bring themselves
fully
and it created trust
in a deeper connection between the team
and from this place
you can do anything
so i think it's really crucial you know
it's challenging for us
i think that beyond challenging
i'm trying to put myself in the position
of the ceo from the first example of
being vulnerable and authentic and at
the end especially in today's market i
mean we're seeing what's happening and
the competition for talent and you know
people have constantly opportunities
chasing them
it must be a really scary thing standing
in front of your employees and sharing
with them listen you know we're not
necessarily doing as well as your friend
who you're seeing on linkedin that that
is that is mainly sharing how amazing
everything is and how good the company
is doing so how do i as a ceo than
cannon how do i how do i know whether
this is a moment of being authentic and
and hopefully rally the people around me
especially if i'm a larger company where
people don't necessarily follow me
they're following their own managers and
the managers managers and i'm
disconnected how do i know whether this
is the right solution or is it in your
opinion that it's always the right
solution
look i think every situation is
different so we need to really be
mindful and present with the situation
however i believe that you know
there's the the linkedin and what we are
showing is the the brand that you are
showing that the company but at the end
of the day our company is built on
people right from people and people are
talking and people are feeling the
culture so if they feel seen and their
ceo
showed up and there to be vulnerable
with them and their manager or whatever
so they feel they want to be part of
this um company so it will have the
results you know it's like a
stone that you
you throw to the river and create
weapons so this is the things that go us
out you know beyond the nice images the
logos the benefits the perks that's nice
to have but it's not enough anymore
people are looking for meaningful in the
workplace to be seen to feel a connected
to have impact so and and be feel
partner be partner of their company
so i don't have you know i don't want to
say always do it because it's not right
feel the situation
maybe not notifying the red delicate you
know
dr carl robinson
how does she call it
on authenticity she said it talks i love
it because she said
choose which parts you want to share and
which part do you want to put behind so
maybe you need to find the right balance
i want you how much i want to share and
how much i want to put behind maybe
in this specific situation i need to
show more this and maybe the other but
so
i think this is the being mindful and
listening and you know another example
you have said you like the examples
i worked with another
vp of a big company that they're going
through
a
changes transformation and these people
would have been a
their terms and condition will be
affected negatively from the the change
and he was coming to consult with me and
he said what do you think usually i
don't tell them what's happening i think
i should tell them to show them they
wrote the picture and then the process i
would tell them i couldn't i didn't
succeed in preventing the situation but
it was afraid the people who leave him
the talented people were in this is was
the thing he was afraid of
and i told him what do you think how
would people react at the end of the
change when they will be affected and
they didn't know anything and they
weren't part of the process
and i offered them to
create because they won't engage right
they won't but they didn't feel
connected and they won't feel part of
the process so they apparently
they will leave
and during the
conversation i offer them to create the
dialogue spaces and to share with these
employees and managers teams the
situation to be vulnerable to be present
and to be there with them and to
listen to them
even sometimes only to listen to them
and to share with them it's enough
and you know after the first time he did
it he came back and i saw he wasn't
pleased and i said i wanted to say
he said not good they say well not good
said they won't
think they're saying
a ventilating and the only a few had
creative ideas but most of them said
really tough things
and i told them look it sounds like it
wasn't easy
but it was really beautiful
because you were present with them
in this unpleasant feeling because he
needed to be in this space right and to
connect to his feelings
and you know in this consulting meeting
he wasn't sure we continue with this
process and after our meeting he
understood that this is the right way
forward and he continued with it
listening to his employee although it
wasn't easy for him and at the end of
the process when they did need to
decrease their terms
most of the people stayed with them and
they really appreciated him for being
with them and seeing them and having
them as partners in the process
incredible i and i love the distinction
between it didn't go well
it wasn't easy
very different things that's something
that i'll continue thinking about karen
thank you so much for for these 20
minutes i really appreciate it it was so
enjoyable for me taking definitely tips
for myself um you'll find me tomorrow
morning standing right over there taking
my five to ten minute break in nature
and trying to
to to keep to to wrap my mind across
what's what's happening and ease the
wonderment and start the day not with my
mind in all different places but but
being much more mindful and much more
presidential definitely keep in mind the
auth being authentic not just with
colleagues and employees also with
relationships it sounds like it's
something that is relevant for for all
of them and and lastly one of them one
of the most important things i'm taking
with me
being able to handle a tough situation
and owning it and understanding that
even if it's rough it doesn't mean that
it's not good it means that it's not
easy but it can actually have some
substantial outcomes for building trust
down the line so so kevin thank you very
very much i appreciate it and stay safe
and stay healthy
thank you very much
[Music]